so you finish limb grave and have made
it into leonia of the lakes whether that
be by defeating godric the grafted or by
skipping stormville entirely and is
starting to dawn on you this game is
kinda
really big well i have a recommended
route you can take at this point and i'm
also going to give you some advice on
the areas immediately beyond leyernia so
that means there will be some spoilers
ahead of here also before i start i
always recommend that you explore have
fun and create your own route
first things first if you haven't
finished stormville and you're feeling
comfortable with it at any point in time
i recommend heading back to complete
stormville and defeat godric if you're
having trouble with him you can summon
the feli lu to aid you in battle as well
as your spirit ashes when you defeat
godric head back to the stormville main
gate site of grace and head right on
through it up into the east near the
giant wolf take him on or run past and
you'll find the limb grave tower bridge
and the way to reach the divine tower of
limgrave head up here and activate the
great rune godric dropped at this point
you can equip godric's great rune at any
site of grace which will raise all of
your attributes so a pretty nice minor
boon to have with stormville out of the
way you start at the lake facing cliffs
to the west before heading down you can
find the church of earth sorcerer topes
and more importantly a sacred tier for
upgrading the power of your flasks of
tears at this point you should be at
plus five if you miss the churches that
contain these the fourth church of
america is located on the weeping
peninsula here the church of pilgrimage
is located on the weeping peninsula here
the calu baptismal church is located on
the weeping peninsula here and the third
church of america is located in limgrave
right by miss wood here in the same
location as the flask of wondrous physic
at this point might as well give topes
10 runes as it will continue his
questline and make it so he'll sell you
some basic spells he also gives you info
on how to enter the academy of real
lucaria our next legacy dungeon and
which is currently closed off to
outsiders sacred tier and a hand we're
going to start exploring leonia which is
a little different than lim grave it
doesn't have quite as many dungeons
tightly compressed in but still has
plenty to find start by heading east and
north along the leonia highway where you
can find your first map fragment in
between the highway north and south
sights of grace you can find a dungeon
the cliff bottom catacombs that i
recommend heading into from here the
question is do you explore the flooded
academy gate town first or along the
cliffside of leonia east there is of
course no real right answer here but i'm
going to recommend you continue heading
northeast along the cliff as this will
take you to an artist shack where you
find another painting you can look for
continue north along here and eventually
you'll find the church of vows i take
you here for two reasons for one muriel
pastor vows which is awesome in itself
because he's a giant turtle but also he
happens to sell both sorceries and
incantations meaning he's a good find
for any spell casting builds
additionally you can give him any spell
book or prayer book you found so he can
act as a teacher which makes him a super
important npc there are other characters
who you can learn these from but it's
always good to find another the other
reason i wanted to take you here is
because the church of vows is where you
can atone for your sins and ask for
absolution basically what that means is
if you hit a friendly npc and they're
now mad at you instead of killing them
you can ask for absolution and they'll
now be friendly again that said it takes
a pretty rare item to do this called
celestial do so don't abuse it next up
we're back to the liernia highway north
side of grace or gatetown bridge site of
grace and let's head into the flooded
academy gate town if you want head to
the south end for stillwater cave but it
is filled with poison
so be careful what i mainly want to take
you to is academy gate town in the
center of the map here you can find
another golden seed additionally if you
run up north and to the east you'll find
a walking mausoleum and the real lucaria
crystal tunnel the crystalline boss
fight here isn't as bad as it might
initially seem as after hitting the
crystalline enough times you basically
break the crystal and start doing
massive damage for defeating the
crystalline you'll get the smithing
stone miners bell bearing one take this
back to the round table hold and you can
exchange it to be able to purchase as
many smithing stone ones and twos as you
like so if you don't like the weapon
you've been leveling up this will give
you the perfect opportunity to level up
and try something new so before we
tackle real lucaria let's actually head
to the north side of the map and to the
northern leonia lake shore just south of
that is the sorcerer's isle and tesu's
rise if you can solve the puzzle which
is basically just finding a bunch of
phantom turtles and hitting them you'll
be able to go inside and get a memory
stone memory stones are viable for any
magic building build as they increase
your memory slots meaning you can equip
more magic at once as well as more
powerful magic head north here to carry
a manor carry a manor can be pretty
difficult so if you're having trouble
progressing skip this step and head into
sierra river and einsteil river which
are going to be what's coming up next
once you conquer carry a manor beyond
that you'll find the three sisters which
refers to three towers ronnie's rise
renault's rise and celibace's rise the
middle of these towers is ronnie's rise
and where we're going to head next i
take you here because it kicks off a
quest that leads to an option for how
you want to finish the game and because
you'll be directly told how to get to
sierra for river if you haven't found it
yet and told to meet blive there you
should now be at the perfect level to
handle and take on sio4 river so we're
going to head there next to do that we
head back to limgrave and mistwood
southeast of the misswood outskirts or
directly south of the third church
america is the sea offer river well
right next to miswood's minor archery
head down the well for one of the game's
coolest surprises seo for river and the
supposed location of nakron the eternal
city i cannot stress how much i love
siora river and how aesthetically cool
this underground city is with its
eternal night sky thanks to what i
believe are lit up glimstones seal for
river is pretty large in and of itself
so have fun exploring it and taking it
on
once you've finished yo for river i have
another surprise for you siofo river
wasn't the only secret underground area
now is the perfect time to access and
find einsaul river remember how i had
you find the church of vows earlier in
this video well head down the cliffside
here from the church of thousand leonia
and pretty much exactly east of here is
the einsail river well which will take
you down into another underground
location from here have fun exploring
isil river the old palace runes and
noxtella the eternal city einstein river
is a little more challenging than siora
river but also super cool and well worth
the visit
at this point it's time
time to head west in lyrnia on west side
you'll find the four belfries which is a
super cool location with warps to
otherwise closed off areas additionally
you'll find the village of the
albanorics this is a critical location
i'm not going to spoil anything here but
make sure you mark it on your map and
try to really really fully explore every
nook and cranny of it another location i
want you to find is the lakeside crystal
cave it's here on the map but that
entrance is actually along the marshy
swamp area of lyrnia for getting through
it you'll find this slumbering wolf
shack another area i want you to mark
alright all that said and done let's
head into rail lucaria to start head up
through academy gay town to the southern
entrance where you'll find a note
telling you that the princess is in
another castle or rather a hint on how
to find an academy glenstone key or your
ticket into real lucaria the map isn't
the greatest but it points here where
you'll have to fight off against a
dragon defeat the dragon and explore the
area and you'll find your very own
academy glenstone key and the way into
the academy of real lucaria i don't want
to say too much about the academy but
there is one interesting thing i'll
point out at the bottom of the giant
lift there's an abductor version watch
out for this specific one because it
really does abduct you if it grabs you
and kills you if that happens you'll be
transported all the way over to the
volcano manor and have quite the
challenge ahead of you
and that's everything i've got for you
for leonia if you enjoyed this let me
know and i'll make a recommended path
guide covering the next section of the
game past ly ernia after leonia there's
basically three areas you can choose
between and the game really ratchets up
in difficulty don't give up skeleton and
i'll see you guys next time peace
[Music]